okay for people joining us we are
looking at multi-computation and wolfram
language design around that concept
and we are mostly looking at the
uh this object multi
um we're looking at some examples here
okay so let's go ahead and make a random
graph
now what is this saying
what are the arguments of multi again
uh without
some initial condition
and my list of rules were all
it's a one of the
input arguments
but i thought multi was just a list of
expressions what what that's a different
usage different usage you either specify
a list of alternatives or you can
specify
like
some expression and a list of rules
and then the rules
represent
things to be applied
multi-computationally
to this list to this
i'm very confused by this
well the results look like you can
specify a level where allowed to
apply
and things like that
i'm confused can you interpret this for
me so am i starting off with one two
yeah starting with either
a vertex one or vertex two
maybe you would i mean would it make
sense actually to have it so that so
right so you might imagine one way you
could set this up is that the the this
two argument form of multi the one where
it takes a list of rules in the second
argument
maybe it uh
you know you could imagine that it only
takes a single object in its first
argument and then it sort of you know
multi-computationally applies to the
second argument and then if you wanted
to do something like you have here where
you have two things that you could start
with at the beginning then it's actually
that's another level of multi right
yeah right multi-multi
i'm totally confused by why
these things are the same function why
the thing that represents
so i think it definitely has to be the
same object right that they produce yeah
because it's just one but by i think we
talked about this last time the
possibility of having different named
constructors for it
right i mean this is essentially the old
multi-way system this thing here with
the rules
is it not
very close it's just it's a little bit
more general because the
it supports
unifying in both directions
so you can have variables in your
expressions and things like that so you
could imagine that maybe you'd have
multi which which only has that usage
where you give it a list of expressions
and then maybe you'd have i'd call it
like multi-replace or something like
that which is like replace it which is
kind of like
conceptually like multi-replaced list
although i don't think the multi-replace
list can actually quite work
but
yeah right
okay so then so i see so the idea would
be multi
is the pure
you know abcd alternatives
right that's that's the
alternates
and that's what you'd get out
if you
those are the parallel threads of
computation or in a multi
right as opposed to a list this is an
annotated list that represents parallel
threads in a computation is that right
whereas multi-replace
would most likely take a multi
which is an object which might be a
multi and i think it's better to just
think about it the single object case
yes
and then here
it's saying
i don't quite understand this i mean
this is just saying take an element the
n
is simply an element of the first
argument is it not
what are all these numbers here what are
these numbers here
i would have thought
go ahead but one of them is the number
of steps
to do
another one is the level
because it
so so did multi is returning a
multi-object and then graph and
everything after that is sub-values for
that multi-object
i also like to think of the movie itself
some kind of
encapsulation of all non-determinism
that you can think of
i'm really confused here i don't
understand why we're not dealing with
you know there is ultimately a
constructor so multi is ultimately a
lazy object
if i'm understanding correctly so if i
if i said this
multi-nest multi-replace nest or
something because that's what it
essentially is you're doing you're doing
this multi-replace nestedly end times
well well two times in this case uh
well graph is kind already the same
it's
when you construct a graph your edges
are generated lazily it's like you have
a generator of edges in a breakfast
search manner
you just have an initial condition and a
list of rules you try to apply them in
all possible ways to generate
that your transitions and you can do it
multiple times yeah i understand but i
don't understand the syntax
so try running it without the open
bracket graph etc
i did this maybe relates to another
issue that we talked about before though
which is what the the idea of having an
outer okay imagine a summary box right
but
but i mean the the thing we talked about
before about having an outer wrapper is
that multi doesn't uh
you know eat everything
yes so what happened to that where are
our notes
okay
we we feel like we're starting from
scratch i want to see last week's notes
where are they
in dropbox
do you want to see the notes from the
meeting my notes or do you want to see
your notes i want to see what i wrote
so in the dropbox folder there's sw
notes
where
in here in multiple computation
sw notes this one here
no
uh the folder look at that that's from
look at those those are separated by two
by year
and now we're almost another year later
which which folder this one here yes
and then it's 18.
okay can we can you remind me what we
were doing here before we before we go
back
we really got to do this okay can
somebody go through what we had
previously okay so here we had the
concept of a multi
experience rules right and and one of
the things we talked about was
right with this this multi eats
everything that you put around it right
and and you can prevent it from doing
that by wrapping it with unevaluated but
we didn't like that we didn't like that
so there's the idea from what we're
doing
i implemented the idea that
it it doesn't
evaluate inside hold sequence
sequence holds
let's go through
this version what we did here
with whatever has been done now okay
so so that we keep track of what because
i don't understand we just started
something completely new now so let's go
back here
and let's go back to
um mean i think the multi we're seeing
right now is basically is very similar
to what we saw last time it did i mean
it's basically the same thing
yes it's the same thing just with slight
improvements and i try to come up with
some new
uses rather than okay all right okay so
let's remind ourselves what we had last
time okay
so
i see this is saying graph
right that's saying the 10 is just the
number of steps
to running back is this thing
that's the rule
yeah just apply ggg is the graph do a
vertex and you get a new vertices
adjacent to it
adjacency list of the graph comma n
where n is just a number right yeah it's
a vertex
so this is a breadth first search i
didn't know that was what was i didn't
know that adjacency list did that i
thought adjacency list
wait a minute you give it a graph and
you give it a vertex and it gives you
the vertices that are adjacent to that
or maybe you give it a list of vertices
it works too
in this case
let me give it three four
okay fine
okay all right i get it okay so this is
walking along a graph
starting from that initial condition
yep yes
okay i finally get it sorry but but just
to clarify though is it starting from
list one two or is it starting from one
and also starting from two
well in this case one out from two
because it fits at least to the adjacent
side anyway
it is feeding the whole list to
adjacency list so it really is just
starting with unitary object one two
yeah well it depends on what level
you're playing it
you can figure i think without
it's actually applies on this first
level so
all those vertices are applied
individually
okay so it's applying it to one and it's
also applying it to two yeah so you get
an eight from one to its adjacency yeah
okay we get it it's so simple although
it so happens if jason's
listable in the sense you wouldn't need
to do it that way well but it wouldn't
be able to produce that output graph
they did it that way i don't think
but yeah
it would depend how you thread it
you'll get an edge
either you get an edge from one to all
of its adjacency vertices so you get an
edge from list one two
to twelve dollar suggestions
and you won't be able to
thread it correctly yeah okay use the
information okay all right fine so this
is
this is using multi
to do
i mean if i were to make this for
example
um
what's that second two
that's the the level it's like you if
you get the
list as an output
it says that you
basically flatten it up to a level two
so that's because adjacency list returns
a list of
this is sort of solving the nest graph i
mean it seems like that should probably
maybe maybe you should look at how nest
graph does it because nest graph has
some
some whole thing about how you know if
you give it a list it'll assume that the
outermost list is
you know
right
what happened here this didn't give the
same result
what happened can you relate the code
inside the mutual book in the
multi-computation folder instead maybe
something get messed up
so i cannot not do all the
all the code get executed
again
which one you run the whole section it
says code
multi dot nb
this one here yeah
just run all the initialization cells
okay
okay let's try this again
okay i don't understand
oh
i could pick up that graph in case
something depends on that particular
graph
oh it's like
it's just multi it doesn't work at all
even the boxes for it
maybe a new session
start from scratch
okay
okay all right so anyway this example is
supposed to be showing us
um
a breadth first traversal is that
correct
yes
what version are you running
well something
not a prototype just the usual one well
but you're running thirteen one not
thirty no correct
work
well they're not so
okay well maybe we can just look at the
we we know what it's supposed to return
yes
but i'm trying to understand what the
point of this example is the point of
this example is you have a bunch of
walkers walking around this graph is
that correct
in parallel
is that the correct takeaway well not
exactly in parallel just just in breadth
for search you get your rule says how to
generate new edges
and that's it
right conceptually in parallel but not
not the parallel map if you don't know i
understand but conceptually in parallel
that's what we're dealing with with
blocks in general it's conceptually in
parallel you start from you start from
those two nodes
and then
in parallel you walk to every successive
node where you do it twice here right
am i confused
right so it technically would be
concurrently but not necessarily
parallel but yeah
okay right
let's look at completion here
it does seem though like i mean again i
think we talked about this like last
time that that it would be useful to
have
you know to to change the design a bit
so instead you have some inner thing
called multi or something like it and
you have some outer wrapper
that like
oh effectively what it does it just
stops the multi from eating things but
but you can format it and like document
it in such a way that really you know
you have this like
outer wrapper that's like
non-deterministic evaluation of blah
blah and then in the blah blah blah
that's where you put multis and stuff
and so
it's kind of like a framing construct i
don't know i i think there would be i
think that's right yes
nick what do you think about that
no i think that there are many
alternatives and i'm not sure yet
what is the best design because there's
not much use cases
yet to be yet explored all right okay so
by the way i gather that you've been
spending some time fixing find
uh equation of proof
that right
in a way and this is also
uh provides this new
source of rules that you can get for the
multi computation
because find the original proof thing
what you've done is you've made the
proof functions
be correct is that right
yeah and that too yeah
so there's the proof function
uh the proof function is correct for the
critical polymers and also
dig deep in the world meister code and
also export how completion works and can
you
how can you make interface around it
and it's not like it's not going to work
for you because it's going to require
some
another version for the world meister
another build
okay but they actually have this
interface around it the just uh
that just makes a completion so you
provide it
with a bunch of axioms like axiomatic
fuel group actions it's just a bunch of
equations
and it will just produce a list of
equations the list of rules
with the inside of the object so all
those rules actually
have a proof
and this is
completion rules you can use for
your
motifing
or generate a new graph
so admit this is equivalent to
in the in the meta mathematics thing
where we have group axioms and we're
going
in two directions with these group
axioms this is
the thing
that
makes one directional versions of those
is that right it's a minimal set of
completions that makes one directional
version
that are confluent so if you just use
them in order to reduce some equation
some expression in the group
of the group it's going to reduce it to
a normal form
that's cool
does it work
well it works on my machine currently
only okay okay so so if i were to add
something specif
you know specializing this to a
particular group i will be able to make
canonical forms of words in the group s3
or something
is that true
well that's the idea yeah it's not
guaranteed to always produce you a
finite list of rules
this is here there's unfailing
completion yeah yeah so
it i also made an effort to make some
kind of
time constraint so
if you're just gonna abort you just get
all the critical polymers at this point
and you can apply those
and hopefully they reduce your
rights because they might not because it
might escape somehow
it might need a a completion that was
not actually generated
yeah but i think it's in general the
critical paleo size of the expressions
actually growing in size
so if you're just reducing a tiny
modest expression it's always going to
reduce to something
not at all
okay
so
one of the complicated things is so and
you know we've got this confusion about
how we represent formal variables and
whether they're blanks or not or
whatever
um which i guess you are putting another
you know
yeah
you're making another assumption about
that but let's not worry about that for
right now okay this is cool so now what
um
so this is basically to talk about what
what can we
do with automatic fear improving in
general it's like it may
use be used for some kind of pathfinding
right yes
yes okay but okay well let's take a look
at some of these other examples here
this is the
this is something that i found
it's to talk about this difference when
you share the smoothie object or you
sure you have two coins at the same coin
yeah
so
it's like that that's how they do it in
different logical length programming
languages that's how you can do it with
this multi object
with this function applied to the coin
okay
and i have more examples of this logic
programming
in the mutual notebook currently
if you wanna look at this
okay
in this notebook here yeah
because
i was just playing it with today
so in this in the same logic programming
section
i was trying to solve this einstein
puzzle a smaller version of it
with just a bunch of rules
see how the graph gonna look
oh yikes
okay i'm not completely understanding
okay so look
when people talked about prologue back
in the day
what did they think they were going to
use it for
because whatever they thought they were
going to use that for something we think
we can use this for as well
yeah well
i'm not really sure what the actual use
case i don't think
many people actually use ecological
programming
it's just fun for some
[Music]
no theoretical purposes explore some
well perhaps perhaps
you know back in the day
it was supposed to take over all of
computing
just so you know
okay and i mean i don't know how many
times people showed like the n queens
problem and things
but
i mean again we know we want i mean like
maybe you had an example here for random
walks and we know we want
i don't know but but i mean we want
these things that will give you the
density i mean we've just discussed
haven't we james you you've discussed a
bunch of other examples
of cases where we want
i mean every time we've made a
multi-weight graph in any of the
projects we've done
we should be able to do that very
cleanly with this multi-computation
system
yeah
i'm aware that we've discussed other
examples that can be used
usually when i discuss this with nick
nick agrees that
there are some applied examples that
he'd like to try
but
that there are other core more
fundamental aspects of multi that he
wants to spend his time on it doesn't
feel like just enumerating examples
but then then then
we need to know what the design is and
and i don't understand are we converging
on the design are we not converging on
the design i mean it seems like we've
we've been around several times here we
we know look the the case that i know is
going to be useful is find replace path
because i you know there are lots of
things for which that is directly useful
so let's make sure that we can easily do
that with this you know with the setup
can we
you know and we know what that is that
is you start with an initial condition
you have a bunch of rules yeah i know
where to finally replace pathways
we can do it
right
yeah we can we can do it it's just a
matter of efficiency
i know i know i know and the the whole
point is to have a design
and then in different cases we'll either
use automatic they're improving or other
techniques to be able to do it i mean
what we know we need we need to make
entailment cones we need to make find
replace path
we need to be able to make we've
enumerated these i mean many of the
things that are in multi-way system
already are things we know we need
we need to make the whole graph we need
to make the subgraphs based on you know
getting we need to you know the the path
we need to make the
the um look all the all those steps are
clear
right okay those but wait but you asked
before you started listing those
applications or the kinds of
uh graphs
or functions that we can
uh
emulate or produce with multi and
there's still these fundamental design
questions
and i i also share what's your what well
yeah i mean i
so
that's what we need to get a list of
right right now let's so nick i mean
last time we discussed this
you wanted to
probe some of these questions
further but
in this agenda notebook these are mostly
applications
what are the key design problems that
haven't been overcome questions that are
still open because we can just discuss
them now
now one of them is just logical
programming i just started like
exploring what are the limitations if
you actually
wanna um
one the design that people care about
when they solve some logical puzzles or
whatever similar to other logical
programming languages if you wanna solve
this kind of problems
now we kind of realize what the
limitations okay so so one of the things
that we've been doing this multi-weight
games project
okay that bradley has been doing okay
we've now got many examples
of games
which could be fed straight through
multi
brad is not here i guess but there's a
there's a huge number of examples now
oh good
cool
okay i mean i can go find it here
um
just
all those examples are simple
multi-way application
have initial conditional applied in all
possible ways
and there's nothing new there
i know but we need i mean i don't know
whether hopefully those are
straightforward
although they have many details
so what i'm saying i mean in um i don't
know
there's new ones here i haven't seen
them
yet
but yeah i think most of these are
essentially entailment tones
standard multi-way graphs
nest graph something close to nest
graphs
and others are
you know finding a particular output
branch of graphs the usual stuff
right the fact that we've already
got versions of these is not a reason
you know that what we're trying to do
now is to clean those things up so that
we have nice good functions for those
it makes sense so there's the question
of functionality
that can be produced using multi and
then there are the deeper design
questions i mean just a few minutes ago
for instance uh stephen you and
christopher you're making these
suggestions about you know wrappers that
can be applied and nick is saying he's
not sure he thinks that there might be
other alternatives i mean those are
those are fundamental design questions
can we please just try and air those
today
yeah now i think we should
let me let me just write down some
design criteria okay
okay design objectives
reproduce
all known function all known
functionality
all useful functionality
of multi-way system and it's many
variants
okay so that's one objective
right is to go through
all of those and that's that's not the
that's not the first thing that will be
done though right
that's what we have to check from a
design point of view
anything sure you know reproduce
find replace path
okay what else from a design point of
view
i think the other thing we want to do
is
interaction
with evaluation graph
that was the other thing we want to do
where we're basically we're
understanding
how to get you know how to do
multi-way evaluation
that was the next big thing but this
these seem like applications of multi
no no they all inform the design of
multi
this particular thing but what is but
what are the open questions in terms of
the actual guts of multi that still need
to be figured out okay hold on hold on
hold on hold on because whenever i
discuss the applications of multi with
nick
nick suggests that there are deeper
questions that have to be resolved
before so what else well exactly okay
nick what are the deeper gut level
aspects of multi that still need to be
figured out i know we just take the
first bullet point here about the
reproducing the multi-way system it's
like what exactly they're producing
things there do you want to produce all
the causal branch of graphs for all the
type of systems that it
supports currently well all useful
functionality i don't know some of them
may never have been used
okay but yes we're going to want to look
just like we have token event graphs we
have all these kinds of things we need
to be able to
that that includes you know token event
graphs et cetera et cetera et cetera
we're trying to make something which
takes all of that stuff that we've built
and
you know
just streamline the design and get
functions that can actually be built
into the language
but again the thing that was what
started this whole effort
okay there are okay
other design issues
we also talked about well and
side
project slash designs
another one is
manipulation of pattern expressions
because that's relevant to completions
you know unification rather things like
that
right that that right now you know eg
for two-way rules
does that make sense
yeah
i mean it seems like we already have
established that there's going to be
this object or there's going to be some
head called multi
and it's going to represent all these
kinds of uh
all these kinds of things and the real
question is just how you construct them
and how you query them
yes
this represents
multiple threads of computation
in some way
right
and it might be explicit it might be
lazy there might be an infinite number
of threads
whatever
right
and so for example examples of
operations i thought we already listed
these things like
um
you know
um
generate the graph the multi-way graph
yeah generally generally generate
different graphs
yes generate a graph
representing
a multi-multi-way system some multi-way
system another would be
essentially
does the output
contain
some desired
thing
eg satisfiable let's say
you mean search
yeah i mean so it is equivalent to like
when people do things with
non-deterministic turing machines
yeah
does the output ever contain this
desired thing okay then there are other
ones we already listed which are things
like
find the
largest
thing by criterion x
in the collection
okay these are these are not the design
goals that i'm i'm hoping we'll be
listing as you've mentioned steven we've
discussed these before already and they
haven't been done they haven't been done
i know so we need to do them
that's not my point
the point is they haven't been done
presumably because there's some obstacle
okay so what's the obstacle exactly okay
so that we need to we need to identify
those and list them so that we can start
keeping track of if we're making
progress on them or not well i know it
so i don't understand the obstacle i
thought we had a design that was that
had some questions about it but we had a
basic design didn't we well obviously
the the authority on the obstacles could
be nick because he's the one yes i know
i know i know so nick
go it's just
well it's pretty hard
no i
started this object with just one idea
it's like would it be cool to have this
thing
that just bubbles up and makes
everything
non-deterministic
yes
okay so now where are you getting stuck
that's my question
or are you not in fact stuck is it just
a matter of that it's hard and it takes
more time
it's it's unclear what to do next it's
like i have a bunch of ways
to
you
generate
to traverse this object right
but i don't think is it unclear because
there are too many things to do or
because there aren't enough things to do
maybe not enough
it's like it's some of the things are
pretty clear what to do but not clear
what the design should be so you can
make a graph what else can you want what
what else
we're starting we've made this list
multiple times
for example
you know does the output contain a
desired thing
well if you have a graph you just no no
no no no no no you can do it more
efficiently than by generating the graph
yes and of course also you don't know
how far you'll have to look right i mean
you may have to look
yes much further yeah
find the path to a given thing
which is otherwise known as theorem
proving
yeah so so you might you want to make it
just more efficient
no i i want a design for all these
things but first can be totally
inefficient
just so we have a design so we know how
to represent all these kinds of queries
because i don't know yet whether these
queries should be
you know properties of multi i'm not
sure they should be or actual functions
that you apply to multi
right i mean it seems like basically
there are right conceptually most of
these things you can get from the graph
because the graph at some level you know
represents the same information that you
have in the multi although
i mean not not quite obviously but it's
close
but but the point is that
you know
both for convenience and for efficiency
it's much better to have dedicated
functions for doing these things as
opposed or you know dedicated mechanisms
for doing as opposed to generating the
graph and then querying the graph
because
even trivial things like like you know
if you just want to know if some vertex
is included you know you need to set the
settings when you generate the graphs
that you don't generate uh
you know you don't generate multi edges
if you know what i mean like you don't
have a multi graph
this is very confusing to use turn
multiple something else but but you get
what i mean you don't need self loops
and so on you know
to be more efficient you want to do that
but i mean it's just much easier if if
it's its own
function or property or whatever
well to be clear when i say it
to generate a graph and not
always mean that actually graph the
actual graph is generated it's just you
have a generator of edges but you may as
well don't build a graph you just
use
the right hand side of those edges okay
to just to traverse them
and look for properties in there
if that's what you're trying to do yes
but i mean the other thing you might
want to do is actually generate the
graph
that's one of the properties is generate
the whole graph including self loops
including multi edges etc yeah
but but i mean the whole point is we're
gonna there's a list of like 10 of these
or more
that include you know branch of graphs
foliations all this kind of thing
right fine
it made for an analogy right if you
looked at like
i mean this is a pretty random one but
like if you look at like the
documentation from uh what is it called
uh
linear optimization
right it's got like
when you do some linear optimization
thing there are like maybe 10 different
things you can ask for and many of them
are almost equivalent to each other or
they're like trivially attainable from
the other like for example you get the
the solution matrix or you can also ask
for basically you know the the loss like
the you know what what the optimizer was
but it's of course trivial to compute
the loss from the
optimal matrix but it's still useful if
you can just ask for the different
things that you want
right like those first two primal
minimizer and primal minimizer rules are
like
you know there's no reason to have
primal minimalizer when you also have
primal minimizer rules i mean the
information is just a pure subset but
it's still convenient to have it
right i mean
nick is this is this making any sense or
is this still
min yeah it's still it's still pretty
shreddy it's like branchial grass causal
grass they all seem like a
post-processing thing
that depends on what system you're
actually exploring it's like
okay but but look look the thing that i
think is holding you up
is you are trying to figure out what is
the internal data structure for a multi
is that right
yeah yes the foundation of minimal one
yes
okay
that can generate all of these things
oh what can i help you to produce it's
like seems like it's already enough
and just too much of
i know just okay so then what i would do
is
you know just start trying to do these
because some of them will be easy to do
some of them you will realize oh whoops
we're not storing enough information to
do that
i mean i i think
you know in the end all these glocal
multi-way systems and so on we're going
to need a lot of that stuff but we don't
yet know how that fits into this
because the most straightforward thing
is global multi-way systems
i mean okay i'm trying to understand is
the thing that's holding you up you
don't know what's inside multi that will
then be exposed with different
properties
is that the issue or is that a different
issue
well
i'm not sure it's like
if i had a
very clear objective that would be much
okay i'm giving you objectives here
reproduce all useful functionality of
multi-system
okay
that's an objective multi-system is a is
a
you know and it's relatives
right
by that you mean though that multi-way
system i mean there's two parts to that
one part is
multi-way system has many constructors
for like different types of multi-way
systems yes that's right that's one
thing
the second thing which is probably the
more immediate
immediately doable thing where the
design is more obvious
is
it has many properties that you can ask
for
like the state graph or the branchial
graph or the whatever graph
yes
and and i should add there are some
things like the event branchio graphs
that i've asked around and i'm pretty
confident no one has used
um
right right well it might still be worth
yeah fine right i mean maybe it's not
worth getting every there are a lot of
properties but i mean oh my god there's
a lot of problems i know i know i know
one of the points is these properties
were invented this was a research
function
okay
and things were done
both in terms of the internal code
and its efficiency
and the way things were exposed
for research
now what we want to do is take what
we've learned from that
and make a sleek
you know thing
that has you know
consistent naming efficient
implementation
that you know
this this function the fact that we have
a combinator multi-rate system or maybe
it's called multi-way combinator system
and so on that's a separate function
from this
is just not the way it should be
but it was done that way correctly
in the research phase
that makes sense i mean like like the
way the multi-wave system is specified
here with
you know like this this is all fine but
not what we should ultimately be using
i mean that that's
and you know a lot of these things the
event selection functions and so on
these are essentially foliations but we
need different ways to specify
foliations
i mean it's a giant conceptual cleanup
that's needed
so so nick i'm still
well it's not just i'm not i'm not going
to quote jonathan because i i've i've
given jonathan such a hard time for the
i'm confused by what you're confused
about
the so i won't quote that but go ahead
please
um
i'm just going to say it's not just
cleanup because i think even the
research part has haven't been finished
because with those with all of those
mathematics stuff
there's another kind of rom that's been
opened with different kind of
unifying
yes
but probably
possibilities
and different things you can match so we
are also upgrading it to all general
terms and not just
like given systems
i i agree but i mean it's just like look
the whole two-way rules thing the whole
notion of bi-substitution and so on
these are all
a bunch of additional pieces look this
is a big complicated design but i think
what we wanted to do
you know
oh yeah i mean
if it's not obvious how to go forward
with this design i mean i guess
yeah
um
i mean do we have this complete list
with all the stuff that we learnt from
the mathematics project
all the different kinds of graphs all
the different kinds of replacements and
so on
have we at least made that list i mean
these lists have been enumerated several
times during these live streams
they've been enumerated several times
during the live streams
and then you know nick when we discuss
it it usually seems
as though there's something more
fundamental
that
is
the subject is the object of your
attention such that you don't want to
start doing these examples there's
something else you want to figure out
well we haven't discussed it for a while
but
maybe i have a better idea now
you mean you made a better idea of
what's wanted or you just had a new idea
about how multi should work
no just what just wants it
right i mean i think that but let's look
at the the sort of the shining
okay i just want to say that the thing
that i really saw see as being the the
real objective here
is
how do we take the language
yeah as
as represented with all these you know
again let's let's review the road map
we're trying to make these
trace graphs
okay
for our ordinary evaluation
it's
let's go through this again our ordinary
evaluation
is single way evaluation
yes if we traverse an expression
we get a result
now
again
so that means that
the
representation
okay so wait a minute i i'm now again
getting confused
there is a representation
of the traversing expression and get a
result which is
uh the evaluation graphs that ian has
shown examples of that
i was calling it trace graph can you
i mean it's in 13 1 it's in the trees
context
okay
all right so we've got this tracecraft
thing
now
the goal is
imagine that we go multi-way
with the trace graph
okay
then
all the things that we imagined over
here
about things we could do with
multi-computation because in again
reminder
with ordinary single way computation the
thing we are primarily interested in is
the answer
now there are different forms of
computation like the ones that we need
for i don't know reinforcement learning
or something like that
where perhaps that's not even a good
example but there are cases where we
don't just or dynamic even where we
don't just want the answer
right those are different uses of
computation
does that does that make sense
or for debugging or tracing we don't
just want the answer we want to see even
for single way computation we want to
see the path by which we get there
sure that makes sense yes
okay
so then
the goal is
what if we could be running on many cpus
and we could go multi-computational that
is if
this is what we've discussed previously
if instead of our usual evaluator we
have a multi-evaluator
that instead of
you know a particular transformation
being done there's a list of three
transformations that could be done sure
and we go multi-way on all of that
then the goal is
at that point it's not useful to say
what's the answer because there isn't
just an answer
and then we have to make use of all
these things we've discussed the branch
of graphs and all these kinds of logic
programming kinds of things they're all
relevant at that point because there
isn't just an the answer
but the goal the original goal was
to try to understand
in a situation where there isn't just a
single the answer what are the
appropriate language constructs to deal
with that case
so for example the things we're
listening here would be what we would do
is we would just have you know we would
expect to have
a
you know a multi-evaluate
okay which is what we've discussed many
times
which were in which
or something like that
in which there are at various stages
there are multis
that i don't know i i don't even know i
you know again we've been through this
various times but i mean something like
um you know n goes to multi n plus one n
plus two maybe would be an example of
something where you're saying
uh that
in that computation in that evaluation
that's a place where you have a branch
into multiple threads
and then the goal is
to be able to insert that anywhere
in our evaluator
and
to be able to see its consequences you
know the most
basic
um uh
you know the most basic consequences
would be things like is there a path to
this can you get to that
you know the probabilistic programming
what's the distribution of you know
what's the how many paths are there can
you get a path of this length et cetera
et cetera yes and many of those things i
believe will be a family of 10 or 20
functions
that are the core functions of
multi-computation
just as we can say replace nest function
application and so on these are the core
functions of single-way computation so
similarly i think there are core
functions of multi-way computation and
the not very easy project
is to kind of find all of those
right now to implement them just to find
them no no no no with implementation
that might not initially be efficient
implementation in all cases
i mean we're never going to know what's
reasonable unless we implement it
so what i'm saying is
you know like if you take
you know
what should it look like i mean all the
stuff we've done multi-way you know
systems and numbers all that kind of
thing
you know a lot of that was done with the
multi-way system function but what would
be the minimal way to deal with those
kinds of things just using multi and
using
you know whatever this object is the
computation object the multi-computation
object that comes out from lazily
uh you know because because again our
usual computations are not lazy
because we expect they will be finite
and we want to get the answer from them
right these ones have to be lazy
because
well
for two reasons one because
i mean maybe they they they may have
multiple answers so it's not obvious
what you would give as the answer
and also
a large part of the story of what's
useful in almost every case is the is
the graph by which you get to answers
not just the answer itself
i mean look those are the two things
that are different you know with trace
graph we're saying we don't just care
about the answer we care about how you
get there
just like in all right theorem proving
we don't just care about
sort of
you know whether whether such and such
an expression is true we also want to
know how you get there
is this making sense i mean
the
it's a high level
program
it makes complete sense
right
i know i know and it has to be broken
down i guess into
into pieces that
that but but
nick i think you know you've managed to
come up okay even this thing about
pattern manipulation is something we
know we need
right that's a component we know we need
yeah like a bunch of things like
canonicalizing
unifying those right exactly exactly
including the very difficult thing that
you've done about generating these
completions
i mean that's a part of that story
yeah that's that's in progress
right so i mean that's a definite piece
to this
i think the the piece that is important
here
is
i mean look
okay
i have not seen to the end of what the
design should be with multi and all the
pieces around it
okay i was
uh
i think
i think the right thing to do here is to
start building
the things that we're describing here
even if
you know
i mean your concern is you just can't
write it the underlying data structure
is going to be is that right
oh it's not even clear that
everything should
revolve around multi it's like all those
pieces can be
independent
all of which pieces
it's like find the path branch or graph
it's like it shouldn't be just one thing
that produces them no i agree that's why
i said i think there are 10 to 20
functions which are the generic
functions just like you know length
depth whatever those are functions of
expressions
similarly i don't know you know
all kinds of things are are the generic
functions of ordinary computation what
we're looking for is the generic
functions of multi-computation
and the thing is that what i've imagined
is that
that we need a computation object
to which we can apply let's say a
function called branchial graph
what i'm saying because i i don't think
i mean right now okay the big
generalization that we're doing here is
there are two generalizations and
they're related
we have a representation for expressions
we do not have a representation for
transformations but you know the the
story of a transformation between
expressions aka proofs aak computation
you know paths trace graphs whatever
that's what you know we don't have a
canonical representation for that
then the next level of that is when we
go beyond that and we go to the
multiversion of that
we can hopefully use
essentially the same representation
as the full history included
representation for the single way
conversation
does that does that make sense
kind of but lazily
no way right
right that's what i'm saying i'm saying
i think the right thing to do
is to
have a thing that specifies here's a
computation that we want to we want to
specify the computation we get a lazy
computation object out
and then
well just like you know a sparse array
or something you don't actually know how
many zeros and ones it put down anywhere
you can just ask it for
you know the determinant of the sparse
array or something and it magically does
something inside that hopefully doesn't
actually explicitly generate the million
by million matrix
this is the same thing you ask it for
the branchial graph at level seven
um you know with this flat foliation
boom it generates it for you what did it
do inside did it have to go to level
nine in some places etc etc etc we don't
know all we know is that we asked it for
the branchial graph at level 7 and it
gave it to us
yeah that's example kenda
it's you need to generate a bluff it's
unclear how to just make it more
efficient than that i understand so so
the thing to do is start by generating
the graph we know there are cases like
the find the specific output case
which what could just be
you know look it could be that the way
that works
is
find replace path or find
just find path
of
uh you know computation object
comma
well i don't know maybe you just have to
give a destination here i'm not sure how
that works
okay i'll find shortest path or whatever
that could be that the computation
object
is you know that computation object is
as if it is its evaluation graph
for purposes find shortest path
for
all
instance
and then
i don't know exactly what that returns i
mean that's what we have to work out is
whether that just returns a list of of
things on the path whether it returns
the graph fragment whether it returns a
highlighted graph i don't know what that
returns
um
well for the case when i i have an
equation of version of finding a path
which is not that far from just a
general one that uses an automatic film
improver
just right and it can return just a path
and
it's justification
it's like when you what axiom your point
what orientation at what position
exactly but the point is that's not what
an ordinary path
okay an ordinary path from a graph for
example just gives you a list of
vertices
it's thought to be self-evident how to
go from one to the next because in fact
there has to be an edge in the edge list
of the graph that goes from one to a
next but in the case of replacements it
is not so obvious how you get from one
to the next
if it's a replacement and what it has to
do is another thing we've discussed
previously
which is
this representation of how a replacement
got done
in fact you've even you've even got that
function nick you've got a lovely
function for doing this
that gives the details of how the
replacement got done
right yeah
it uses a equation of path
so the it's not just rules the two rules
basically so no but you've got a
different different thing which is your
i think your multi-replace which says
here's the you know given an expression
[Music]
and given a rule
here are the ways that you can apply
that expression
that rule to this expression and where
does it apply and so on
sure yeah that's
yeah you just can nest this multi place
and well that's essentially what muji
does when you give it a rule it just
nests this multi replace with all its
information
so all those edges are tagged
with the olden the necessary information
exactly and and then you know you should
be able to get the token event graph out
of this et cetera et cetera
i mean i i suspect that we should have
functions i mean i think these concepts
are strong enough that i think it's not
a bad idea to have functions called
things like you know
token event graph broad shield graph i
mean why not
you know we've been using these for
multiple years now and they're really
quite robust concepts i think
well we just have those
what's that we already have those
but not in a decent design i mean sure
i mean we have those as properties into
a multi-way graph thing
where we have you know 18 different
kinds of
of multi-way graphs
that
you know jonathan has
correctly generated for 18 different
research projects
okay the goal here is to have one
unified thing where we can
uh you know where we where we learn from
what we've what we've done
and you know try and make a unified
design
well the causal graph is interesting
i would happily discuss how how it will
make a unified design for that
i have some ideas but
good
yeah good i mean listen nick i you know
the reason that we were proceeding in
this direction is because you've already
invented a whole bunch of stuff here
that seems like it is exactly the raw
material needed to execute all of this
but i think
you know
i mean at the minimal level
just knowing how to take all the stuff
we did in the matter mathematics piece
and make that nice clean code that's
very simple
you know that already will be very
useful
but i think as we do that we're going to
learn other generalizations unifications
etc
plus
the big thing that i've said for the
last month or two
is the real thing that i want to see
happen
is this generalization of our evaluator
to a multi-evaluator
and knowing what's involved in doing
that so to speak for which we need both
the kind of thing ian's been doing with
trace graphs
and
the kind of thing you nick have been
doing with with multi
to bring those things together
yeah well that's completely unclear how
to do where's the
where's the middle ground i don't know
wait wait wait wait why is that
completely unclear
we've got this notion of a trace graph
we went through with with um
uh with ian what's the different kinds
of edges in a trace graph
right those edges are time-like edges
space-like edges basically
now what we've got to do as we add multi
to that is to add branch-like edges
to the trace graph
what does it mean we have to
how how do you actually do that
you modify the evaluator itself or you
make your own from scratch
we'll have to make our own from scratch
for now
i mean this is the this is a prelude to
actually doing that for the evaluator
and you know to actually do that for the
evaluator we're going to want to make it
so that it can actually run concurrently
which we think
you know the compiler will for example
help with and so on i mean this is
complicated seriously complicated but i
think the first step is to do it
in a
you know in a sim the first step is to
get it working with pure replacements
where everything is just a
transformation rule specified explicitly
as a replacement
it's a different thing which ian has
worked on for trace graph to deal with
down code and so on as well as the down
value stuff
ian do you have any comments on this
i
don't
think that i'd yet see a
a way that
that the trace graph ties in with these
branchio graphs because i think most of
the detail
that you see here is not actually
corresponding to things in the
multi-framework it's just
no it's not visualizing the
a particular evaluation sequence yes a
particular evaluation sequence the whole
point is if there was a different
evaluation sequence think about it
coming out of the page
okay a different evaluation i think
you're thinking like well multi is like
maybe you can traverse the expression in
different ways
no
no i'm thinking there are two rules that
can be used at a or b
and there is a branch for a and a branch
for b
and right now all that our evaluator
does is pick the first one that applies
and go with it
okay the multi version of that picks
both of them
well i kind of had an idea just
well the rule version already exists
can you open 13 1
and run trace graph real quick so i can
illustrate something
okay go ahead so do trees back tick
trace graph
and then copy out that code from the
expression tree example
this here oh just the inside of the
trace
is that going to set a global variable
i don't like that
so
the the dashed highlighted edges
represent the application of a
transformation rule
that is the step that you're mentioning
now about you could have
exactly different replacements applied
there or you could have
the same replacement applied in
different positions exactly and my point
is
like my point is literally everything
else in this graph is just an
implementation detail of the evaluator
that i don't think has any general
relevance
i understand that
i mean this represents the actual
sequence of evaluations that happen well
because so so nick has a graph i i don't
know what the code is but he has a graph
that can reduce this into a causal graph
which gets rid of all of the all the
extra nodes in here
so
sure of course he can
but the the causal graph involves these
things which book should become
bipartite those things should become
events in this case they're one-to-one
events
they take one expression and they
replace it with one expression
right
okay so
and the point is i'm not i'm not
representing in there anything about
which rule got applied or where
i know
which is something that nick is going to
need so i'm saying you're not just going
to extend this graph and then get a
branch yes you are
yes you are because you actually don't
care about look
this graph does not contain the raw
material for this graph does not contain
all the data you need this is what i
keep on saying that you know the the the
thing that nick has already built
okay for
has
um
okay
nick has
much more heavily instrumented
replacement rules for example
which is what you need
you know what we've done again
summarizing our evaluator is an answer
only evaluator
do you see what i'm saying
our evaluator has currently configured
all it does is tell you the answer
right
what we need is an increasing amount of
information about how it got there
now for example in our proof objects
we've got a version of how you get
information okay the proof object and
the proof function
which the proof function should be an
implementation of the proof object i
think
but both of those things are
descriptions of not only what the answer
is but how you got there
that makes sense
yeah yeah right
okay but as we've gone through in great
detail
the proof object
is a single path right what we've done
and what we did in metal mathematics and
so on is there's a whole entailment
graph
of which
the proof object is just one path in the
entailment graph
so the goal here in this picture would
be to represent
not just the evaluator in its single
path
but the multi-evaluator in which
essentially every one of those events
doesn't just have one possible output it
can have
there can be multiple events that can
take place and they can have different
outputs or in terms of this picture
you're essentially going out of the page
and you're showing in addition to this
started line here there's another
possible dotted line that will be a
different evaluation
does that make sense right and i'm
saying that all the other edges
don't have an analog in general because
those are edges that just represent the
implementation
of the evaluation that's not true they
have that's yes yes okay listen listen
this is the difference between these
global multi-way graphs local
local global et cetera et cetera et
cetera this is the exact issue is the
same issue that we have with the physics
project with space time
versus etc is each of these pieces is a
piece of an expression one thing we can
do is say we go whole state of the
universe to a whole state of the
universe there's an analog here although
it's a little bit more complicated
because of this tree-like structure
but we can also say
many of those
sub-expressions don't change when you
just make an evaluation over here in
this corner
am i making sense
i mean so the the nodes in this graph
need not be sub expressions they just
are arbitrary
subsidiary evaluations i know and so
that's just an implementation detail
about the replacement rule itself which
says this replacement rule works in such
a way that it has subsidiary evaluations
yeah what nick has just works with
arbitrary it's like this much more
general thing already
you can give it any rule
look we're trying to take our evaluator
and make it a multi-evaluator our
evaluator does specific things you could
imagine a different evaluator that does
other things
but what we're trying to do is take the
formalism that nick is generating and
apply it to this case now i would like
to see how we generalize what we're
doing just like we can think of our
evaluator as applying transformation
rules
right it doesn't remember where it
applied them it just applies them it
tells you the answer it doesn't remember
it it only does one path of them it
doesn't do transformation rules in all
possible places it just does one
sequence of them
right the goal is to represent the case
where transformation rules could be
applied wherever they apply in parallel
does that make sense
right i mean
i understand that generally i don't
understand it with tracecraft
i don't either trace graph is an example
of a representation of single-way
evaluation we need a generalization of
trace graph that would work for
multi-computation
right i don't think the trace graph in
the case of down code is the best
example because down code as opposed to
replacement rules when it is dominated
by down code down code is something
where we have to go into the inners of
the system to make that
multi-computational
whereas a little bit more obvious going
from replace to replace list how we make
rules be multi-computational
see what i'm saying
no no
you don't understand okay
all right look
we're really late for something else so
okay
i think
wait can we please you know precisify
state what what's the next step that
we're going to take because i want to i
don't want to repeat this meeting next
week
i'm not going to repeat this meeting
next week i'm i'm saying
hold on hold on yeah i know there's a
whole list
what nick what's the what's the most
natural starting point let's just pick
something maybe one or two things to
begin with there are there are side
shows like the manipulation of
expressions with patterns
that would already be a very useful
thing there's an overwhelming number of
different ways in which we can approach
this i don't think that's i don't think
that's acceptable just to have this list
to say okay let's try it let's try one
of these let's just no
no no no no no no i'm saying
what we're trying to do
that is something which is completely
factored off from everything else here
look basically
it's going to take me doing a bunch of
heavy lifting to to you know to try and
corral the central reasonable design i
do not have time to do that in the next
week
okay therefore working on something like
the um
you know pattern
manipulation of patterns which nick
already has a bunch of of of
of thinking and code for seems like a
reasonable thing to do given that i'm
not gonna have a chance to go through
and try and do this design
which you know
i mean
i i'm
i'm a little confused by why we're so
stuck
because i thought we were we had a
definite path here
well that's no good because i'm also i'm
also confused why we're stuck i am also
confused and i'm meeting with nick even
more regularly than you are okay well i
don't think so
this is okay
i think we're stuck because nick wants
to make
a solid foundation for this and we don't
yet know what the solid foundation is is
that is that a fair characterization
nick
or not
maybe what i also think that the
foundation is kind of already there it's
just
it's just i don't know what else it's
required but look it's just
transitional pieces on top of it i know
but but it's not just additional pieces
each one of these as you start digging
into it will turn out to have all kinds
of complexity
this is not as straightforward as it
might appear
you know not to make a decent design for
all of this stuff
for example we have no way to specify
foliations
we don't know how to do that
so you can what context you
want to specify them we can enumerate
them
no but i i know i know i i know i know i
know but we want to have that's the
whole point we just like breadth first
search depth first search
um you know ian's traversal orders tree
traversal order functions and so on
these are examples of foliations
that's the place we start implement
those
maybe we find a generalization of those
but i mean we don't even know how to
implement those like like if we were
going to do something which is the
multi-evaluate function with a traversal
order do we know how to do that a little
bit
close to we don't fully know how to do
that
no i can't okay it's kind of clear
if you have a generator of a graph
you can also specify some strategy how
you would want to traverse it even
before you actually generate it fully
excellent that's what we need
and it needs to you know that that's
look
the things we need for find replace path
are a rule-based graph generator
rules for generating a multi-way graph
and you're saying which is not obvious
to me
that you can also specify
sort of foliation rules in the same way
great if that's the case it's not
totally obvious to me how to do that
oh i haven't said that
for not deflation
the traversal or the information
right okay so okay fine but i mean so
that's the thing
but
um
yeah but but then we've got all these
things here and others that we've listed
before of things that you should be able
to do
from this computation object and again
the thing to do first is implement them
inefficiently and if you can implement
one efficiently great using their
improving or whatever else if they all
have to be inefficient where it's just
generating the graph up to the point it
needs the graph so be it for the time
being
just so we can work out the design
so does that make sense
kind of well
okay what the next thing you want to see
next
i want to see a version of multi-way
system
done with multi or something like that
that involves you know five or ten
functions
that are clean general functions
and that inner thing is able to work
with combinators and strings and this
and turing machines etc etc etc in a
reasonable way that'll be what i would
like to see
and
you know just cleaning that part up
okay what if i just focus on the causal
graph part of it
first because i think that's the most
challenging
well
okay
my strategy wouldn't be to start with
the most challenging part
no because any other thing is kind of
clear how you you do it but can you do
it then do it yes
because i don't think
i don't think it will be as simple as
you think it will be
i think it's going to have i think
they're going to be a lot of issues
and i think we should but by all means
if you look
do the states type stuff
heading for the causal graph
and see you know i think you're going to
find that there are complexities in the
states case as well
and they're things which right now are
all kinds of funky options all kinds of
things you know the the event
decomposition functions and all that
kind of stuff
that are in the current multi-way system
that should be unnecessary
they should all simplify to something
involving multi
i don't see it yet maybe you can already
see it
like i can see it when
because each event each replacement has
some information and all the
necessary information to generate
causality from this it's how those
uh related exactly if there's some
position
then that position tells you whether
those events are causally connected to
that
yes
no i agree i agree
so
look why don't you try to implement it
to the point where you get to causal
graphs but you will get other things on
the way
rather than just a causal graph or we're
not going to understand what we have
well the state's graph already have a
state graph it's just what you if you
just query graph
property from the multi that's the
state's graph oh you're fine
but okay but how do i do find replace
path
that's what i'm asking i keep on asking
the same thing how do i do find replace
path for let's say a numerical multi-way
system
how do i find the number 11 in a
multi-way uh in a
um numerical multi-way system you know n
goes to n plus two n plus three
well just uh
well
right now there's no way to do it but
it's as simple as
just
take this each generator and stop when
you find your desired pattern
well except that we would like to make
it so that it can use theorem proving
and doesn't that inefficient
well if you want to make a
use of if you're improving
you have to make it at least equational
or think of it ordering so that you
kind of fix the order of your equation
somehow well it's already already then
it's already kind of working you just
yeah
okay but but kind of working versus
versus you can tell me exactly what to
type to solve the particular problem i
just just gave you i mean look you know
we know that you can do that by saying
okay if i say nest graph
n goes to
n plus two and plus three
start with one for example
and go
four steps
okay now
i can see whether i can find you know in
that thing i say find
shortest path
in that one comma 11 let's say okay
great there we have it
okay
so
that's this way of doing it i'm asking
how do we get
a you know
right i mean
it's like with this other formalism how
do we get the same thing
well it can make appropriate just
searches for 11
and just returns a path without changing
i'm not sure that's the right thing to
do i i'm telling you i think what we
want is to have that computation object
and have a limited number of of serious
functions that do things on that
computation object just like we have a
certain functions that do things on
graphs like find shortest path for
example
but then why do we need the object in
the first place
because it's not all generated in this
case we're generating the whole thing
right and then we're doing fine shortest
path the whole point is we want to have
a laserly generated object
for which we can then ask for sure
without generating it it's just the
object itself is just a holder for your
rules so we can regenerate whatever it's
generating inside of it
it's like
not done no but what i'm what i'm saying
is
what we need is something that says you
know multi i don't know what the right
thing is okay so maybe it's some you
know i don't know whether this is right
but something like multi-evaluate of um
uh
this goes to multi
n plus two n plus three
okay
but then that's you know starting with
one
and that's it that's the that says
multi-evaluate that that says we're just
going to do it we're going to keep doing
this until we reach a fixed point
which in this case will never reach a
fixed point
am i making sense
so then we say something like
um mean i'm just making this up i mean
i'm you know fine shortest path 1 comma
11. in that
and so the way that would work is this
thing
returns a lazy object
which fine shortest path is overloaded
to deal with just like it deals with
graphs
that would be my concept something like
that
is that is that crazy
a little bit
tell me what sure how the end to multi
and blah blah blah i'm not sure if that
can work but
yeah
i mean it's defining this is defining
look this is the equivalent of the
evaluator okay
i remember this isn't necessarily the
right way to just say stated okay that
think about that as fixed point
okay that's fixed point
where this goes
i'm just going to i this isn't quite
right because it's the graph version of
this but it's going to be fixed point of
this
that's what multi-evaluator is doing
there is like a fixed point except that
that does not terminate
right and also the multi-evaluate acts
like that unevaluated that that prevents
the multi from expanding forever
right yeah this thing returns a lazy
object
right yeah fine that doesn't hasn't done
any evaluation at all
it's only when fine shortest path hits
it that it says oh i need to go and you
know set this up as they're improving
and go find that path right that that
returns the multi-object i'm just saying
it's equivalent i mean in terms of
implementation this is almost identical
to what already exists except that this
multi-evaluate thing is here which which
serves the same purpose that unevaluated
did in some of the earlier examples that
nick had yeah probably so i mean i think
nick has already built a lot of this i'm
just saying that it has to be packaged
in such a way that you know
nick does this packaging make sense to
you
well in the case of the shortest path
i'm not sure how it it's
assumes that you do it at the
breakfast scan of your generator i don't
know what short spot means
this is why i'm saying it's non-trivial
i mean this this will depend on
traversal order and so on all kinds of
stuff here that's why this is not the
zeroth thing is just to get it so that
you have multi-evaluate that produces
the multi-object and then you have
functions or properties or whatever for
accessing the graph and whatever other
things you want and the secondary thing
is to
write up values for functions like find
shortest path so they can take the
multi-object and then do the right thing
with them
right and realistically by doing the
right thing with them you know most the
time this is going to be it's going to
access some property and then it's going
to run its normal behavior on that
property
so maybe the question here is what are
the useful properties for
useful algorithms to use
it's like
documentation for multi-way system right
yes because those are a bunch of
properties that we know are useful for
these kinds of multi-way processes right
and probably the thing to do is just to
start with you know
pick your favorite five you know like
state draft and stuff like that and get
those just as a start
and maybe get a few you know a few of
these
operations these algorithms and and
i mean the goal again is
to make this
you know we're trying to generalize the
evaluator
and
you know initially let's try to
generalize the pure
non-down code evaluator
that is the evaluator whose sole
function
is
i mean you know the analog of the
evaluator that is uh replace repeated
okay so i mean it's it's like you know
initial step
the quotes replace repeated evaluator
does that make sense i mean that so
that's the same thing that i was talking
about was find replace path
it's just you give a list of rules
that's the same thing you've got in
token event graph and other functions
you're just giving a list of rules so in
the case of
one could make a version of ian's
trace graph that just is a replace
repeated evaluator
does that make sense
well
that's that's all we have already
i i agree i don't think it's a version
of the tracecraft i think it's a graph
that nick already has
okay well i can imagine
that trace graph
can be placed inside of the
usual lower replacement it's whenever
the right hand side rule evaluates i can
just place this trace graph inside as an
additional information
you're not right that it's different
okay this is the whole point is these
red lines right now
are you know
imagine that there's a replace repeated
around this whole thing every red line
is a particular rule application from
the outer replace repeated but these
other things here well this one isn't a
good one this is a bad example because
this is using down code it's a bad
example but if it was just recursing
through an expression there would be a
space-like separation of pieces of the
expression that it would be going
through separate from the time-like
uh application of the rules
right but my i guess
what i would say to that is that replace
repeated recurses through an expression
the evaluator evaluates the head and
then decides on subsidiary evaluations
and i'm saying
that
look replace repeated has the same
feature that the evaluator has but it's
going to a fixed point
right
it's repeatedly evaluating that's what's
happening in the time-like way that this
is going this isn't a particularly
interesting example
but when you re-evaluate something in
you know in the evaluator that's what
you're doing you're doing it like
replace repeated
well they're both like fixed point
yes
yes
i mean this is a really bad example i
mean like let me do a replace repeated
example okay
but i won't be able to do it very well
because the most obvious replace
repeated okay so let's do this
replace repeated i mean that
let's say
uh s5
slash dot
x blank goes to
uh
explain goes to x minus one
slash at x greater than two
okay
off regards sake
that does terminate right am i going
crazy that terminates right
what's happening there you rule the lady
all right
all right what can i do here with okay
there we go
all right i don't quite understand how
this is doing okay this is doing it in a
rather confusing way because it's using
down code
do you see what i'm saying
i i don't actually know what you mean by
using down code this is look it's using
the fact that this can just work with an
arbitrary nested list in principle and
you can represent it as a dag in this
way
okay but but the thing that i was
expecting was to see this thing and then
next the other thing and so on you see
what i'm saying
rather than this sequence like this
which is what i would expect to see in a
list
this is showing the evaluation of the
replace repeated expression
it's not showing
the
traversal that replace repeated does
through the expression
okay all right
well but it needs to show that in
general right in order to make a trace
graph you need to show both the space
like recursion through this that's like
a replaced repeated graph
yes that's what i'm saying that's what i
keep on saying i'm saying you need a
replace repeated analog of the evaluator
to see this
and i'm saying it has that
okay but but and i'm saying you don't
quite have that i thought you were going
to get something closer to that with
this
i mean this isn't meant to to show a
replace path it's meant to show the
evaluation
i know
i know
but i'm trying to say
a simple version of this is to use a
replace repeated evaluator because it
has less issues than the actual
evaluator once we understand that with
next technology how to do a replace
repeated evaluator we can come back to
the main event to the real evaluator and
see how to use that technology for that
that makes sense
sounds like the right way to attack it
right so it will be good to have all of
your technology in applicable to a
replace repeated a quotes replace
repeated evaluator
right so we're doing the exact same
thing that we're doing over here for the
main evaluator for the replace repeated
evaluator
that make sense
it it does and i'm saying how's that
okay i've got to go i'm super late i've
got to go
um
i i hope
we've got some path forward here
do we think we do have or do we not
think we have and if we really don't
then nick you should work on this
pattern
transformation you know pattern
manipulation thing because we know that
that's a worthwhile thing
if we think we're stuck on this still
we'll have to wait until i've cleared
what i'm doing right now
we at least have a sub list of things to
work on this week including pattern
manipulation
let's see
sure i can start progressing with that
sub list i i think nick i think you're
going to find this is going to be great
i'm i'm i'm i'm i don't quite know
what's blocking you and i i'm concerned
because
i i think that that means there's
probably some big problem here that i'm
not seeing
well maybe
nothing was blocking me i was just doing
some side question to automatic pure
improver instead okay all right fine
fine okay terrific which is very good by
the way that's a very interesting very
worthwhile thing okay well so so maybe
this meeting was a null meeting
because we already had this list okay
gotta go
talk to all